si queremos entender de dónde venimos
las historias que nos han llevado a
nuestra condición actual si queremos
entender nuestra historia
uno de los prerrequisitos es tener un
buen sentido de la cronometría
y cronometría suena como una palabra muy
rebuscada pero simplemente en la ciencia
del paso del tiempo cronos se refiere a
tiempo y junto con metría es la medición
del tiempo damos por sentadas muchas
cosas en la actualidad suponemos que
sabemos lo que sucedió en los últimos 50
años en los últimos 100 años y ahora
empezamos a suponer que sabemos lo que
sucedió 10.000 años atrás por lo que le
sucedió al planeta 100 millones de años
atrás o un billón de años atrás pero
todos estos son fenómenos muy recientes
esta habilidad de arrojar algo de luz a
lo que sucedió en el pasado e incluso
las nociones tradicionales de la
historia las historias tradicionales de
que llevó a que las naciones políticas
que se formaron las migraciones de gente
y cuando ocurrieron esa noción
tradicional de la historia es bastante
nueva cuando la comparas con el tiempo
que creemos que los humanos han estado
en este planeta
y esa primera noción de la historia la
puedes ver como la primera revolución
cronométrica y esa primera revolución
cronométrica que nos da este tipo de
noción tradicional de la historia surge
simplemente de la habilidad de escribir
de la humanidad la escritura
nos da nuestra primera
revolución
cronométrica
porque esa fue la primera vez aunque
creamos que los humanos o criaturas
parecidas a los humanos han estado
presentes por cientos de miles de años
en este punto no fueron capaces de
mantener sus historias en una manera muy
exacta tuvieron una tradición oral las
pasaron de una generación a otra pero
con estas tradiciones orales muchas
historias se perdieron y la información
más importante que se perdió es hace
cuánto tiempo estas historias empezaron
y no fuimos capaces como especie de
realmente tener un buen entendimiento de
cuándo sucedieron las cosas y hace
cuánto tiempo sucedieron las cosas hasta
que la escritura se volvió la corriente
dominante y hasta que la escritura se
hizo de una manera en la que se volvió
permanente
y nuestra mejor noción de en qué momento
esto sucedió la primera vez fue con los
sumerios y la escritura cuneiforme y
esto sucedió alrededor del tercer
milenio antes de cristo hace
aproximadamente cinco mil años antes del
tiempo presente y así es como se veía un
fragmento de la primera escritura
esta es de hecho una carta me parece que
es de un rey y puedes ver que son
grabados con cuña altamente simbólicos
esto es lo que tradicionalmente
asociamos con cuneiforme y tenía una
base simbólica en contraste con la
actualidad la mayoría de nuestros
idiomas se basan en la fonética así que
tienes menos símbolos que pueden
representar más significados pero podría
decir que esta era una gran revolución
tecnológica para la humanidad porque
ahora con la llegada de la escritura
cuneiforme tienes escritura permanente
que alguien podría haber mil años
después dos mil años después y si pueden
descifrar la escritura cuneiforme pueden
obtener un testimonio escrito de lo que
estaba sucediendo en ese momento y no
tienen que depender de una tradición
oral o incluso adivinar cuando esa
historia oral pudo haber iniciado pero
la escritura ya que apenas surgió al
de cinco mil años atrás aquí tenemos
años
podrías decir antes del presente o
podrías decir tres mil años antes de
cristo ese fue el inicio pero esto sólo
nos dio historias de hace cinco mil años
atrás e incluso entonces fue un registro
histórico escaso no obtuvimos realmente
muchos detalles de la historia
dependiendo de en donde te encuentres en
el mundo hasta los últimos pocos miles
de años pero fue un inicio esta fue la
primera revolución cronométrica pero de
lo que podrías o no ser consciente es
que francamente creo que estamos en las
primerísimas etapas de otra revolución
cronométrica que apenas se ha comenzado
a acelerar en los últimos 50 60 70 años
y esta segunda revolución cronométrica
bueno antes recordemos que la primera
revolución cronométrica nos permitió
conservar el tiempo de una manera
permanente entender cosas no tener que
hablar con la gente a la que le sucedió
algo lo podemos ver en su testimonio
escrito
pero la segunda revolución realmente
surgió de la llegada de mucho de nuestro
entendimiento de la ciencia moderna a
finales de los 1800 la radioactividad es
descubierta por marie y pierre curie
aquí tenemos a
esto es relativamente reciente recuerda
estás hablando de una especie que ha
estado presente por varios cientos de
miles de años y los proto humanos han
estado presentes por millones de años y
ahora son los cinco mil años atrás por
lo menos hasta donde sabemos fue el
primer escrito y luego apenas hace cien
años fue el descubrimiento de la
radioactividad
ratio actividad
y luego la habilidad para usar la
radioactividad la radioactividad es
interesante es la idea de que
esencialmente los elementos pueden
cambiar de una variación a otra de un
elemento durante periodos largos de
tiempo mediante la radioactividad por lo
que se convierten en una especie de
reloj natural
nadie tuvo que ir ahí e instalar un
medidor de tiempo para ello
afortunadamente existen estos elementos
que decaen a una razón bastante
predecible
descubrimos la radioactividad hace un
poco más de 100 años atrás y luego en el
transcurso del siglo 20 nos volvimos
cada vez más sofisticados en entender la
radioactividad realmente para ser
capaces de usarla para medir el tiempo
de las cosas y si avanzas en el tiempo
rápidamente a la segunda mitad del siglo
20 ahora digamos que estamos en 1950
aquí es cuando la segunda revolución
cronométrica realmente se arraigó aquí
es donde se arraigó realmente cuando
comenzamos a entender cómo datar con
carbono 14 empezamos a entender algunas
de las otras técnicas que mencionaremos
mientras empezamos a adaptar cosas cada
vez más antiguas
y quiero ser clara la radioactividad la
comprensión de la radioactividad fue
sólo el inicio de la segunda revolución
cronométrica la segunda revolución
cronométrica de la cual francamente
seguimos siendo parte no es sólo la
radioactividad también es entender la
expansión del universo la constancia que
tiene que ver con el límite en la
velocidad de la luz que ahora nos
permite descifrar wow esa radiación de
fondo que estamos obteniendo tuvo que
haber estado viajando hace 13.7 millones
de años atrás así que ahora podemos ver
evidencia de nuestro entorno y nuestro
entorno no es únicamente la tierra es la
radiación bombardeándonos desde el
espacio que nos da pistas de no solo
nuestra edad de la humanidad de la edad
de especies la edad del planeta más bien
la edad de todo el universo por si mismo
así que no es sólo sobre la
radioactividad
la radioactividad es una parte
importante de nuestra revolución
cronométrica esto es lo que nos permite
por primera vez saber
si tenemos capas en la tierra la gente
sabe desde hace mucho tiempo que si
suponemos que estas capas no han sido
alteradas que algo en una capa inferior
aquí abajo será probablemente más viejo
que en una capa más arriba porque año
tras año tiene depósitos y no ha sido
alterada de alguna manera pero nadie
sabía decía está bien esto es datación
relativa
esto es más
antiguo
reciente
pero no tenemos manera de decir oye esto
tiene 1000 años y esto tiene un millón
de años pero ahora con la radioactividad
podríamos empezar a decir que podemos
datar algunas de las piedras aquí que
tienen 150 millones de años y algunas de
las piedras acá tienen alrededor de 100
millones de años así que quizá este
fósil
un pez que encontramos o esta criatura
primitiva parecida a un pez por aquí
este fósil tendrá entre 100 y 150
millones de años y la única manera en la
que podemos hacer esto es siendo capaces
de datar cosas utilizando la
radioactividad pero la radioactividad es
solo el comienzo de como mencioné
comprendemos cada vez más la cosmología
obtenemos mejores mediciones del
universo por si mismo estamos
entendiendo a la física en un nivel más
profundo ahora podemos empezar a ver el
genoma y pensar en cómo el genoma
diverge de una especie a otra y qué tan
rápido cambia todas estas cosas nos
permiten obtener cada vez mejores
refinamientos en la cronología
obviamente este es un inicio pero aún no
sabes por más o menos 50 millones de
años que tan viejo es este fósil y cómo
se relaciona con otros objetos que
podamos encontrar
solo quiero resaltar esto que lo que
ahora damos por sentado la edad del
universo la edad en la tierra de cuatro
y medio billones de años los humanos
existiendo por alrededor de varios
cientos de miles de años este
entendimiento es un fenómeno muy muy muy
nuevo se dio debido a la segunda
revolución cronométrica de la cual creo
aún somos parte e incluso la primera
revolución cronométrica esta versión de
la historia y quiero aclarar la historia
fue limitada por esta primera revolución
cronométrica fue limitada por lo que se
documentaba pero ahora quizá podemos
expandir nuestra noción de la historia y
muchos de los vídeos en los que he
estado trabajando
han sido para el proyecto gran
historia
que dice hey antes de que la historia
fuera limitada por la primera revolución
cronométrica por lo que fue escrito por
lo que era testificado por la gente y
fue hecho permanente de alguna manera
ahora la cronometría nos ha conducido
para que podamos entender cosas en una
manera profunda antes de que incluso la
tierra existiera así que por qué no
redefinir la historia en una gran forma
para abarcar todo para que sea una gran
historia de todas maneras te dejo aquí
de hecho quiero también poner énfasis
que la segunda revolución cronométrica
es un gran logro nos permite transformar
incluso nuestro entendimiento de la
historia pero incluso esta primera
revolución cronométrica justo aquí cinco
mil años aún no es tan largo en el
completo alcance de incluso la
civilización humana